[Music]
how do you feel about raw meat diets
i think there's people that enjoy it
[Laughter]
you're a politician man people that
enjoy this good have you have you tried
raw meat uh yeah i tried like raw liver
the the trend that's everything oh you
did did you get a big chunk or small
it's just like a tablespoon full what
does that taste like
ass was it pork or
uh beef beef yeah so it's like uh it's
like just flesh and you just just
draw
yeah and you did that for how long no i
just ate it one time oh just to try it
let's try it what the hype was about
it's [ __ ] gross man i had a raw beef
i like lean ground beef all that like in
um you know that korean
bean bib or whatever yeah yeah there's
one time i ordered it and i didn't know
it's gonna be raw meat and it was just
the raw meat salad thing and i'm like
let's go you know and then like
there's that and then there's um
there's actually people eat like raw
chicken now in japan
it's like a whole thing
it's like chicken sashimi they have to
marinate like salmonella
they have to marinate a specific way to
kill some of the i don't know how it's
done but yeah they're they i mean
they're they're careful i guess i'm
hoping i mean i get the beef part about
it but the uh the chicken and pork i'm
like isn't there a bunch of [ __ ]
diseases from [ __ ] i know there's like a
beef tartare dish there's a lot of
vietnamese dishes that have beef that's
what i'm saying i'm like familiar with a
lot more but maybe just hearing about
all the others well i guess when i when
i start really hearing about rami daiso
i'm like seeing people [ __ ] eating
like
bison heart yeah you know what i mean or
like seeing people eating pig's brains
and [ __ ] like that yeah which i
understand is like way actually more
nutritious than just the protein element
have you seen the liver king
yeah that's why i thought you were yeah
yeah
i i i um i was looking around instagram
and this guy pops up and he goes this is
what i eat in a day that food has like
yeah he's he looks like a caveman but
he's the reddest human being i've ever
seen he's bright red yeah right
i don't think so and he's eating like
raw eggs
he's eating like basically it's all meat
carnivore right and i sent it to barton
i'm like is this guy on steroids or is
this just a lot of protein i'm talking
about this guy
oh he's the other oh i saw him he's
another guy he's another guy
he's been dubbed uh the wolverine i saw
him
i saw him drink like yeah
he's got brain right there he's another
guy going around too yeah but i mean the
romney diet is uh like i see him uh this
is a do you know who heidi montag is
sounds familiar she's married to that
guy that sells crystals
crystals yeah he sells crystals but this
is also her uh eating a bison heart why
is she eating outside like that this is
to help her pregnancy
or no she's not pregnant yet this is to
help her purposely doing it when the
paparazzi around
she's very open about it talks about it
online and stuff like that um just stick
to ginger man
yeah
but i mean it's it's clearly a it's a
big thing going around right now yeah
but this is this is how all these diet
trends go it's just like it's hot for a
little bit you get celebrities doing it
and then
we'll see where it stands in a couple of
months this man right here dubbed the
wolverine right he's a health and
fitness coach um
and uh he's been talking about it
obviously on social media bart is
familiar with the two about his raw meat
only diet with brains being his dish of
choice
uh i don't know how to pronounce his
name so
i'll leave that to everybody else but um
he obviously he's got this carnivorous
appetite uh where
he is originally from lebanon lives in
l.a found himself getting a taste for
eating raw meat and says he would
regularly chow down on five plates of
raw organs for each meal as an appetizer
five plates motivated by a focus on his
overall wellness he later went on to
follow a plant-based diet however this
didn't last long because he claimed that
he began experiencing health issues as a
result from the plant-based diet
after paying a visit to his doctor who
claims found inflammation in his
digestive and nervous system
he switched back to raw meat meals and
has no regrets
he's sad agency from the plant-based
diet maybe he said as i adopted this
diet i started reading books about the
benefits of me and a lot of conor
carnivore doctors eat their meat raw so
i decided to go for it and now his diet
consists of 90 raw meat and a whopping 4
500 calories every day in a bid to build
his muscle
um
what's his name
jordan peterson oh yeah he's on an
all-carnivore diet and so is his
daughter because they had of uh uh
autoimmune exactly yeah yeah yeah and my
actual uh my friend has started talking
to me about this too not raw but a
carnivore diet like literally like not
eating a bunch of other [ __ ] and when he
was trying to explain kind of like some
basic stuff to me because i was like the
food
he was talking about how like
um a lot of people talk about how uh
back in the [ __ ] you know uh ancient
civilizations issue like that or or just
like um i was about to say americans
human beings evolving and stuff we
weren't uh
planting or doing anything like crops
for a long time because everything was
much more like hunter uh gathered like
right so so we were always kind of just
eating meat and in the same way that uh
animals is what he said animals develop
things like
claws or fangs or stuff for defense
plants that couldn't defend themselves
physically develop things like poisons
and random things like that so human
beings actually eating things like
plants a lot can develop a lot more
issues or or find
you know
poisons if you will that are harmful to
our health whereas meat is kind of like
our natural diet fighting for that
and i was like that
kind of makes sense
the plants that we eat they're all
manipulated by ancient humans too
they're not like naturally growing in
the wild stuff but it's like over time
you know every time we've bred the
poisons out of some of those plants
and also cooking it too yeah also
cooking it and also for me like i
like from my perspective i don't ever
like jumping on
uh a method i like focusing on the
result and then choosing the most
effective efficient method to reach the
result right so if it's longevity then
i'm like what are the okinawan grandmas
eating and if they're drinking miso soup
every day you know then i'll do that
versus i think the trend right now is
just jumping on any random method
whether it's keto or going vegan or
carnivore or
macros or whatever people jump on the
method without seeing what the actual
result aspect and they don't even know
what their result is they're just like
oh people
there's a guy squatting every day i'm
gonna [ __ ] squat every day yeah for
real and that's what it is right it's
like you look at this video and you're
like dude this [ __ ] guy is super
jacked he's telling me that this guy is
just eating
brains and an organ meat and he's going
to be jacked like i could be jacked like
that's what people are really attracted
to and then they come up with a
rationale for all this stuff afterwards
yeah yeah right because it is the hot
thing but then if we like and honestly
too it's like there is no secret what
really works is boring as [ __ ] and
nobody gives a [ __ ] really like you you
could tell dude you could tell anybody
what the secret of longevity and life is
to a certain degree and they're going to
be like oh cool and not do any of it but
then you show them something like this
and then becomes a trend that everyone
starts talking about it's just so hard
to not want to be like i'm going to try
some [ __ ] organ meat today you know
and that's all you do for your for your
protocol so it is kind of interesting i
think everyone should try
whatever they want to try and experiment
and see how they feel
um but i think the argument that i've
heard at least against the like so
there's carnivore where there's people
they still cook their meat then there's
a more extreme one where it's raw meat
and then there's even more extreme one
which is organs so the organs one the
the argument that i've heard is any diet
you six
you're able to stick to is
sustainability how sustainable is it to
go to the supermarket and buy organs all
the time yeah you're very hard to get is
it expensive so it sounds expensive and
you just don't have [ __ ] aisles full
of hearts you have aisles full of
chicken thighs you know so it's one is
sustainability how sustainable is it and
financially sustainable because it might
be expensive and the other one is the
parts that they're not talking about is
you have all these micronutrients that
you can only get in the brain liver and
all that stuff which is correct the
thing is you can also have micronutrient
uh poisoning you know just like how you
can get it from plants so over
consumption yeah like if you have too
much iron or too much vitamin a like you
can have poisoning so there's a
difference between like eating like five
steaks in the five brains yeah yeah and
um i've heard another one where
if you want to mimic like because
they're what they're trying to do is
mimic what a natural human would have
done back then right but
a natural human
what anthropologists say is that most of
the time they were starving yeah so you
killed dude
that's the number one thing you don't go
to the grocery store and you're well fed
with 3 000 plus calories every [ __ ]
day of protein like that's unrealistic
right that have all these choices that's
why i come up on 12 eggs every day and
that's why that's why a lot of people
especially in america that's why a lot
of people have a really hard problem
with like
like weight and stuff like that and just
the food they consume just in general
like as a nation yeah we do have our
problem the availability is too high but
and that's what it is and we don't know
how to deal with it because we don't
know what we're eating if you did it the
exact same way it's like you won't eat
for three days and then you eat like a
steak yeah and then that's it or maybe a
heart and then you don't wait and then
you die at like age 28 and that was a
long life that's basically oregon trail
but i do think though there's there the
cool thing about these different like
alternative food movements though is
people are discovering the importance of
like what they
put into their bodies right because like
we were told like the food pyramid and
all this stuff and then everyone kind of
believed like yeah you just eat a lot of
[ __ ] grains don't eat meat because
that's going to make you fat drink
yourself milk drink a lot of milk
whatever whatever and then we're
realizing like oh damn dude there's
actually a lot of different alternatives
to uh
what you can do and how these health
problems that we're getting is through
food um the carnivals the carnivore
stuff i actually tried for a week do you
have diarrhea dude i had
heartburn like i almost vomited like
every night like no veggies no fruits
only just cooked meat and then because
the the research behind it is like so
you supplement like i'm thinking where
do you get the vitamin it's like oh
no you get it through the organs the
organs actually have a lot of vitamins
you know from heart and whatever liver i
couldn't really do the liver but i tried
it anyway
and then so by day three
maybe i was eating too much protein
because i was also trying to eat my body
weight in protein
so then
at one night man i just kept like like
getting these heartburn feelings and
then like stomach acid would be going
acid reflux yeah and i was like
did it for a week every single night
after the third day it started [ __ ]
hurting like crazy and i'm like i got
you know oatmeal or something
yeah dude what do you ate the oatmeal
did you feel better i felt better and i
was drinking um
apple cider vinegar i like that like
apple cider vinegar helps with heartburn
but it's like your body now has to maybe
it's in shock because now it has to
produce so much more stomach acid to
break down all of that [ __ ] protein
takes longer yeah yeah but i almost
choked on my vomit like because because
i woke up coughing from the heartburn
you felt like you hit it pretty hard
though as soon as you switched over
like when you started eating a lot more
meat as soon as like the day you went
with carnivore did you feel like you ate
more than usual
no not really because like um if you
think about like the density of meat
like i'm a filet mignon if you get lean
or whatever like it's actually kind of
small
and if you're only getting like a
hundred and what fifty to sixty grams of
protein a day if you break it up to
three four meals it's not that big
the people that i've seen that have
stuck to carnivore
and uh
and has made it sustainable i see like a
rotation of steak eggs and salmon yeah
and they like kind of like i should have
done facebook
switching and switching and switching it
and i've seen some people see pretty
good results and it seems like they feel
good but i feel like everyone like
everyone's body is different you know so
when i was when i was doing keto and you
were like stop doing queue
because i was
cause like when i did keto and i would
just eat tons of meat and
i was like super super healthy like poop
right well yeah the only drawback is i
couldn't [ __ ] and because of that every
i've done keto maybe three or four times
and i would drop like 18 20 pounds every
time
and uh the
the thing that would happen every single
uh keto cycle is on the second week
i i would get uh these
internal hemorrhoids that would just
burst i had hemorrhoids that's when i
said don't do it
yeah so then i was like you know i got
him i mean i'm in great shape i feel
good all my autoimmune stuff was gone
every time i did keto just the
hemorrhoids are killer i just have the
bloodiest shits of my life so i'm like
maybe that's not a good uh trade-off
dude that i'm gonna hit you up later
you